hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys recommended as soon as it
finished it's from the pro chess League
uh uh Indian yogis versus the Canada
chess Bros around aksadvani representing
the the yogis and Magnus Carlsen
representing the chess Bros uh really a
short game uh in the very abruptly and
it really shows how uh how tricky the
Sicilian is and what um you always have
to be very very careful and a move that
you always see and that it played in
pretty much every game uh can easily
cost you the game so let's check it out
around with the white pieces opens with
a Ponte E4 uh we have pawned to see five
Magnus goes for the Sicilian Defense
Knight to F3 we have E6 and now D4 the
open Sicilian is on the board we have
captors captures Knights the C6 Knight
the C3 and now Queen to C7 the bastrical
variation of the taimanov uh G3
preparing to think get to the light
score bishop and A6 taking that B5
square away from the knights uh with
Bishop to G2 and now Knight to F6 by
Magnus we have castles and now just
Bishop to C5 and Bishop to E7 is the uh
standard move for blank here but as this
is rapid Magnus says all right let's um
play a bit of a more active move with
Bishop to C5 going after that white king
uh we have Knight to B3 attacking the
bishop Bishop back to A7 and now Queen
to E2 adding support to that um uh e for
Pawn preparing Bishop to E3 he wants to
eliminate the dark Square Bishop as the
bishop is beautifully controlling this
diagonal and then raunak wants to
execute F4 so here we have Pawn to D6
Bishop to E3 and now Magnus trade with
Bishop capture some E3 Queen captures
and now uh there are a couple of games
that reach this position Knight the E5
is a known move also B5 is a known move
but Magnus castles and it is now as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game uh we have Pawn to A4 again
stopping B5 and now Ponte E5 by Magnus
opening up the
uh the light Square Bishops upon the H3
and now we have Bishop to E6 and now uh
the way you want to play this is uh by
playing Knight to D5 this is now what uh
Ariana decided to do in the in the game
uh Knight to D5 is very nice attacks the
queen and the Knight here and uh if you
do nothing then you just continue with
A5 and you block it Black's position and
if uh black trades Knight captures is
terrible because this um uh picks up a
piece so you will have to give up the
bishop and then you will of course play
Pawn Captain's Knight to E7 and then
something like Queen to D2 you defend
the pawn and it's uh it's a it's a nice
position it's nothing spectacular black
is perfectly fine black and I put
pressure on the on the C2 Pawn if you
play something like c three then black
will be able to put pressure on the B2
Pawn so black is even slightly better
here uh but uh definitely uh what white
should go for uh around it goes Knight
to D2 and this gives Magnus an idea as
now he gave up the control of the D4
Square Magnus puts a knight on D4 now
threatens the fork with Knight captures
on C2 so Rook 8 to C1 and now Rook 8 to
C8 putting constant pressure on that C
file and again the way you want to play
this is by playing Knight to D5 this was
not played in the game
uh but Knight the D5 would be uh the the
way to go for example Bishop captures e
captures and now uh if Knight captures
on C2
um attacking the queen then you have
Queen to B3 and it's a very awkward
position okay you grab the C2 Pawn uh
but you can't really move the Knight
because the queen hangs and if you move
the queen away from the C file then the
Knight hangs so it's a very tricky uh
position uh but uh still the way you
want to play it is by playing Knight to
D5 in the game F4 was played and this is
the move I was talking about at the
beginning of the video it's a standard
move that you always play In the
Sicilian sometimes you prepare it with
some like King to H2 or King to H1 uh
but here it loses on the spot so feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for Magnus uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
this wild idea uh and uh sorry about
that uh something again happening with
my voice uh and for those of you uh who
just want to enjoy the show it is a
queen to B6 this is the move that Magnus
plays and now white can just resign uh
the problem is not only is the B2 Pawn
hanging but also uh how do you defend
Knights the E to check your queen and E3
will hang and there there's really no
good way to do this if you play
something like let's say okay you trade
once you play King to H1 still just
Queen captures on B2 you're down a pawn
you're gonna lose another pawn and it's
just a really really terrible position
the Knight on C3 is hanging uh there's
no defending this and if you try
something like Knights the D1 which sort
of defends the B2 Pawn uh then your real
problem is let's say captors captures
and knights the E2 with check
uh how do you how do you defend here uh
whatever you play is uh insufficient if
you play something like King F2 uh we
can just play Queen captures on E3 but
even if you go King to H2 we still play
Queen captures on E3 and after Knight
captures Knight captures on C1 and after
Rook captures on C1 Rook after d8 and
this is now uh really really bad for for
white white have had to give up the
exchange and there's just no
compensation for the exchange so instead
after Queen to B6 King to H2 was played
but now just uh Queen captures on B2 uh
we have F captures and e5d captures on
E5 and now Knight to D5 we have Bishop
captures on D5 e captures on D5 and now
Magnus played Knight captures on C2 and
he was in this position on move 21 that
around aksadvani resigned to the game as
there is nothing more uh to be done here
he just lost too much material and
there's no way to get the material back
the queen is hanging and let's say you
play some like Queen to F2 is just uh
too easy to trade everything just Knight
to the E3 attacks the rook and F1
attacks the rook and C1 uh the the
second rank is completely in Black's
control there's just nothing here like
Rook captures on C8 You're Gonna Play
Knight captures on F1 with check first
and after Bishop captures Rook captures
on C8 now preparing to bring the Rook to
C2 and okay you can play Bishop D3 but
then Knight captures on D5 and you just
have too much the white has nothing here
and uh another thing which is maybe even
better instead of Queen F2 could go for
the immediate Queen trade still just
Queen captures Knight captures Knights
the E3 and everything just gets traded
off with Magnus retaining a better
position for example Rook fte1 Rook
captures on C1 uh Knight captures and C1
and now let's say Knight captures on G2
King captures an E4 you defend your pawn
and that's pretty much it Magnus is up
to pawns and around I could not interest
in uh playing an end game being down two
pawns against Magnus Carlsen uh that
would uh that that would just be weird
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it these were the standings
um after the game so Magnus has defeated
everyone up until this point and uh when
I started recording the video Magnus was
playing against
um uh against the village so I don't
know how that game ended I will check
and if you guys are interested I will
also uh share the news with you uh so
okay it was a quite a long game 59 moves
uh and in the end uh well I I will tell
you what happened uh did it spoil the
magnus's winning streak so this is in
fact incorrect there is now another game
here vidit versus Magnus and David has
defeated Magnus
um uh in in in the round after this game
uh versus around akshard money so it's
uh probably a great game if you guys are
interested I can show that as well
um yeah I've seen I've only seen the
final position but it looks like a
really wild one uh so yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh a very
short one but it really shows you how uh
dangerous it is to play the uh against
the Sicilian especially this diagonal
I've seen this happen so many times when
white plays F4 uh a bit prematurely like
even one move prematurely before setting
it up or before moving the king uh this
diagonal just costs white to the game
every time so be careful when you play
against the Sicilian and you are
preparing this set for move make sure
that you can actually play it so yeah
once again hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank
Joyce Roseman Lars tisserman Thomas
kovacia and Phil Malthus for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day